appreciate everybody being here today
thank you very much here at the
Washington County Sheriff's Office I'm
Brian samudio public information officer
of the Washington County Sheriff's
Office it's my privilege to introduce to
you Darren Balaam Washington County
Sheriff for proper spelling it's
d-a-r-i-n-b-a-l-a-a-m sure
Brian
good afternoon thank you everybody for
being here today I'm Sheriff Darren
Balaam we are here's law enforcement
this afternoon to provide some
information regarding the accident
involving Jeremy Renner and clarify some
misinformation that is circulated
myself and all the members of the
Washington County Sheriff's Office
family and First Responders send our
thoughts and prayers to Mr Renner his
family and friends and we share our
sincere hope for a full and speedy
recovery with that said here's what I
can tell you today
on Sunday morning at 8 55 a.m a 9-1-1
call was received for a 1050 or a crash
involving a snow cat versus pedestrian
the subject had been run over by a snow
cat in the area of Mount Rose Highway
at 8 57 Washington County dispatch
advised some units and they started in
route
here's where I want to elaborate on the
weather and the road conditions at that
hour
the previous evening we had seen
approximately three feet of snow fall in
the Mount Rose area and multiple cars
were abandoned on the multiple roads
including Mount Rose Highway
additionally while it was not snowing at
the time of the accident Mount Rose
Highway was closed at that hour because
of severe winter weather
of snow which had not been yet removed
from the highway
at 9 30 the first Washoe County
Sheriff's Office unit arrived on scene
the delay again was a direct result of
the weather the traffic moving around
abandoned cars in the roadway and the
closure of Mount Rose Highway
when the first Washoe County Sheriff's
Office unit arrived on scene medical
Truckee Meadows Fire Protection District
and North Lake tiles Fire Protection
District were on scene at 9 37
careflight landed in the vicinity of
Mount Rose Highway
at 9 56 Mr Renner was taken via care
flight to a Reno Area Hospital
now for some details of the accident as
we currently know them
I want to be clear here as well as going
on a major accident investigation and we
are handling it as we would any other
major accident investigation we are
still conducting interviews and
processing items from the scene
based on our investigation Mr reynard's
personal vehicle which was being driven
by a family member had become snuck in
the snow near his home
Mr Renner went to retrieve his piston
bully or snow cat an extremely large
piece of snow removal equipment weighing
at least 14
330 pounds in an effort to get his
vehicle moving
after successfully Towing his personal
vehicle from its stuck location Mr
Renner got out of his piston bully to
speak to his family member
at this point is observed that the
Piston bullish started to roll
in an effort to stop the rolling piston
bully Mr Renner attempts to get back
into the driver's seat of the Piston
bully based on our investigation it's at
this point that Mr Renner is run over by
the Piston bully an eyewitness detailed
seeing Mr Renner getting into the Piston
bully and not seeing him again until the
Piston bully came to arrest and a pile
of snow in front of his driveway
at this point investigation we do not
believe Mr Renner was impaired at all
and we believe this is a tragic accident
the Washoe County Sheriff's office is in
possession of this piston bully and we
are analyzing it to Raw any potential
mechanical failure of why it may have
started to roll
this isn't part of this is part of our
normal investigation process for any
major investigation
as I mentioned earlier this
investigation is ongoing however we do
not suspect any Foul Play I want to
repeat that we do not suspect any Foul
Play We believe this was a tragic
accident
on behalf of the Washington County
Sheriff's Office I want to thank Chief
Summers from North Lake Tahoe and all of
his personnel and Chief Moore from
Turkey Meadows Fire Protection District
careflight and all of our regional
Partners who assisted in responding to
this accident and with that if there's
any questions I'll answer a few
questions
otherwise can anyone
that is on a private road so he can
drive that snow cat uh and in this
instance as Mr Renner always does those
private roads he was being a great
neighbor and he was plowing those roads
for his neighbor because up there again
they had three feet
started to roll I presume that means it
was rolling over no it started just to
move forward
you're welcome
uh for that we're going to refer to the
family I believe they made a statement
earlier today
um on his uh well-being and again all we
want to say from all of us here are the
First Responders uh we are keeping him
and his family and friends and our
thoughts and prayers
does that device have a park it has a
park and so like we would because of uh
this having such severe injuries we want
to make sure that with that mechanical
machine that was there any mechanical
Fair had he put in park or whatever so
that's anything we would do on any major
investigation that we had and so this is
just something that will impound we'll
have our mechanics and our major
accident investigation team go through
and rule out that was medical did anyone
here or any of the officers who
responded provide any kind of medical
treatment when you arrived you know I
would say they all did and after Mr
Renner was run over by the Piston bully
there were some neighbors that also
brought out some towels to help so you
know I want to thank them as well for
their quick response in helping Mr
Renner while all of us First Responders
were responding but uh first aid was
rendered to him
was it hard for the the helicopter to
land given the conditions it was and
that's why it took them a little bit as
I know there's a video already out there
on social media
um just because of the weather all of
the snow that we had just gotten they
had to find a safe landing zone for
eign
there was no doctor on scene it was some
good neighbors of Mr Runners that came
out with some towels and rendered some
eight
and that's what I can say
that part I do not know I just know that
they came out with some towels and
helped them until all of First
Responders could get there
there was about three feet that we had
just received on top of whatever else
they'd received prior to this big
snowstorm but three feet of fresh snow
it did because Mount Rose was closed uh
and as you may have noticed during that
time we had about 13 to 20 cars that
were abandoned from the bottom of out
rows all the way to the top so trying to
get them and get around for the fire
engines the ambulances that's why again
for fire they collaborated from both
sides of the Mount Rose Highway and came
together to help
I just wanted to clarify you said he was
trying to get back into the snow plow
was he able to get back in and then was
thrown out or that part we don't know uh
we're waiting to talk to Mr Renner what
sort of condition was he in when you
guys arrived did he was he conscious he
was speaking to the First Responders
can you comment on whether or not that
part I don't know I'd have to refer you
to the family and let them answer those
or the hospital
learn to how common an accident with a
snow cat is
no not off the top I I would have to
tell you probably there's always at
least because this type of snow cat is
one you'd see at ski resorts that
there's always these type of injuries or
accidents that occur but I the exact
number I do not know
it was on a private road
and then the neighbors that he helps dig
out are all part of that private road
they're all on a private room he never
has to go on
go on public no and approximately how
far from the summit roughly would that
be a couple miles
Uh I that one I don't know if it was the
neighbors or his family member
charity drives what has been your
relationship with you know he is a
honorary deputy sheriff and so when I
took office in 2019 he came and with his
popularity amongst kids in the Marvels
he has a huge impact those kids that he
touched during shop with the sheriff he
showed up and shopped with our kids I
can guarantee they will never forget
that moment that they got he shared his
time with us there and not only Shop
with a few kids but interact with the
kids so he's had a huge impact not only
on this office in helping us with our
Outreach with shop of the sheriff which
is our biggest event but throughout the
community has been very generous and
he's one of those individuals that I can
tell you most of the time you don't know
that he's doing it but he has made a
tremendous impact on this community
uh this year he did not
they know exactly who he is and they
call him Hawkeye and they are super
excited
um even sometimes the parents may be a
little more excited than kids but for us
that's a great thing with the shop of
the sheriff when we do that and to see
those kids and the impact he has has
been truly impactful
for people in that area to own custom
boys or snow caps absolutely or plows or
something because they're private roads
and so they get a lot of snow and that's
they're on roads that are not maintained
by the county so they have their own
means to plow their their driveways and
their roads
okay with that I want to say thank you
again for coming I appreciate you taking
the time and again our thoughts and
prayers are Mr render and a speedy
recovery thank you very much